you gave us a fashion moment come on
listen i guess something this little
little thing when it fits
right you thought you thought it might
not know you could find fake yourself
that's very that's very nice here that's
very nice okay so you come in here 20
nominations just say this is what we're
gonna do
well
absolutely i really like it's a show
about a team what better way than a
bunch of opportunities for a bunch of
people to win you couldn't have known
that you were making this show and you
really like it's almost like that
remember would like to make me the world
and make the whole world sing whatever
it feels like that a little bit after i
watch it it does a little bit no i we
didn't know that going in i i mean there
was definitely a point of view and a
philosophy of the character and that
sort of sprinkled through the show but
had no idea that that people were gonna
be um so so wonderfully thirsty for it
you know and keep wanting to go back for
refills now a little bird told me that
you might have spent the morning washing
your car i did how did you know that
well i mean i didn't watch i went
through a thing i sat in it i sat in and
listened to like jack harlow and like
and just like you know sent texts to
people that i needed to get back i was
like i mean a car wash and toilets when
you have two kids that's the only time
you're after yourself
so yeah i got some work done see that's
what i'm saying listen i didn't know i'm
like is this the process is this gets
him in the zone
i mean jason i know it's e.t i get it
yeah yeah that's what we do yeah right
exactly so how much fun are you guys
gonna have tonight i expect the ted
lasso table to
be a bit of a party i mean it's a good
group
but again i mean not to be a turkey but
with 20 nominations were spread out you
know they couldn't put 20 folks at a
table i mean they could we would have
been just fine you know
no elbows on the table but uh yeah what
i'm really excited about one of the best
things about this is aside from getting
to see folks and and and whatnot in
person again is uh seeing all our
writers all gussied up yes listen the
folks have been coming through yeah the
folks have been coming through and
they've been showing up and showing out
yeah so first she was going to be
partying on our behalf
if not haven't even haven't already
started would be our writers so that
that's they'll set they're the pace car
they're going to set the pace you just
had a birthday yeah yeah yesterday yes
did you do anything fun uh the kids and
i messed around we did a little swimming
we did a little you know um
you know
they woke me up in the morning they came
in and sang not in harmony but you they
did do the birthday song they did the
birthday song yeah yeah which we bought
the rights for you not in harmony not in
harmony not in harmony
you know they're seven and five but
still
they should be able to find a harmony
right exactly we got you a little gift
you did yeah of course we did at dt we
got you a little birthday gift
we should
we don't have to buy let's do it because
we can sing it and not have to pay for
it it's happy birthday happy birthday to
you thank you thank you happy birthday
to you
happy birthday
i mean thank you happy birthday
to
you
come on this is this what a what a
yeah
you
it was yesterday yeah yeah yeah thank
you thank you yeah i aged out of a
demographic i think oh welcome
i was gonna say
you checked the next box
well in case you feel like
we just got you a little present
a little present yes of course what if i
didn't know that right
i don't want it give me something yes in
case you feel like going back to your
roots and putting on a hoodie oh that's
very nice of you guys a zippy hoodie no
less and a medium always a compliment
always you know
they run big they run big but they also
run very soft so it's very nice there
you go in case you feel like doing that
that's why i actually got you a mizzou
hoodie but i didn't i thought nobody
would get the joke i thought nobody
would get the job get it and then you
know and then and then internet would
get the joke absolutely sweet lady
internet would be all over it